[تصفيق]
هذا هو المشهد الذي تحلم به فرنسا كلها
عوده منتخبها من قطر زاهيا ومنتشيا باضافه
النجمه الثالثه على قمصان المنتخب الفرنسي
واول الحالمين ديديشن الذي يسعى لتحقيق ما
لم يحققه اي منتخب اخر منذ 60 عاما
الاحتفاظ باللقب العالمي لكن من سوء حظه
لن يسافر الى قطر مطمئن البال اذ سيخوض
البطوله بتشكيله يغيب عنها عدد من
اللاعبين الاساسيين بسبب الاصابه
هنا في اروقه مجلس النواب ومع اقتراب
انطلاق المونديال بدات الكره تزاحم
السياسه فالاولويه ليست لمناقشه اختيارات
المدرب بل لتشجيع المنتخب
قدرته على ان يكون الافضل والدينا لاعبون
مهره تحسدنا عليهم منتخبات اخرى لدينا
المع اللاعبين في اسبانيا سيمثلوننا وانا
واثق بهم واشجعهم خصوصا انما حققه المنتخب
سابقا يدفع
للتفاؤلؤه
لان ما يهم هو الجانب المعنوي واللاعب
الجماعي والروح القتاليه
ورغم ان المنتخب الفرنسي يؤكد جاهزيته
للتحدي فان بعضا من انصاره لا يبدون
متفائلين كثيره
ومن الصعب تعويضهما في الدفاع ينقصنا
لاعبون مهمون ومن حسن الحظ ان فرنسا تلعب
في مجموعه سهلان نسبيا لكن في الدوري ربع
النهائي او نصف النهائي ستكون مهمه
مستحيله فاذا واجه المنتخب البرازيل
فسيسحق سحقا الفصل
عدد من اللاعبين لكن ذلك لا يعني ان
الفريق ليس قويا نملك منتخبا كبيرا فقط
ربما خط الوسط يبدو ضعيفا واما باقي
الخطوط فهي جيده
الانطباع بان مهمه كليان مبابي ورفاقه في
قطر ستكون معقده يتقاسمه طيف اخر من
متابعي المنتخب الفرنسي
هو الذهاب لابعد ما يمكن في هذه البطوله
يستعد المنتخب الفرنسي والدفاع عن لقبه في
مونديال قطر وسط مخاوي في انصاره من يتكرر
سيناريو مونديال عام 2002 عندما اقصى
المنتخب الفرنسي من الدوري الاول وقت تحدث
الفرنسيون عما وصفوها بلعنه حامل لقب نور
الدين بوزيان الجزيره من امام باريس